the leaders will focus on our support to
ukraine
allies have provided support to ukraine
for several years and we have stepped up
with
more military support financial support
to humanitarian support
to
help ukraine uphold its fundamental
right for self-defense
nato's core task is uh
to protect and defend all allies we have
increased uh
our military presence in eastern part of
the alliance
the nato leaders will today address the
need for a
reset
of our deterrence and defence in the
longer term
and the first step
is
the establishment
of four new bat groups in the eastern
part of the alliance in
bulgaria
romania hungary and slovakia
we need to do more and therefore we need
to invest more and there is a new sense
of urgency and i expect that the leaders
will
agree to accelerate
the
investments in defence to meet
the pledge we have made to invest more
in defence and i welcome that
several allies have already made
announcements
on
investing more in defence
the meeting today will demonstrate the
importance of north america and europe
standing together
facing this crisis
and
we are the strongest alliance in the
world and as long as we stand together
we are also safe thank you
good morning secretary general naval
with cnbc i want to get a sense from you
of nato's understanding of president
putin's actual mental state at this
point because what we understand of
course is that um even his central bank
governor is trying to leave her post and
he's being uh he's seeing some defection
if you will from his inner circle what's
your sense of his mental state at this
point
president putin has made a big mistake
and that is to launch a war to wage war
against an independent sovereign nation
he has
underestimated the strength of the
ukrainian people the bravery of the
ukrainian people and the armed forces
and uh and therefore they're also
meeting much more resistance than they
expected
we need in a way to address
the actions that we see russia is doing
in ukraine and that's also the reason
why we have significantly stepped up the
support to ukraine and why we have
increased the
presence of nato troops in eastern part
of the alliance and increased the
readiness of troops
we do so to be able to respond and and
address any threat any challenge to our
security
and
what kind of decisions and what kind of
uh
decisions they may make in moscow not
speculate further about
it's been that about can you explain if
not why not or if yes it was conditions
nato allies provide
significant military support to ukraine
nato allies are trained tens of
thousands of ukrainian soldiers who are
now on the front line fighting against
the invading russian forces
uh the ukrainian army is much better
equipped much better trained much better
commander now than in 2014
uh and the combination of uh training
and support from nato allied countries
with the bravery and the courage
of the ukrainian armed forces
is is is
enabling the ukrainians to really resist
and actually fight back
the invading
russian army
we
provide ukraine also with advanced
air defense systems with anti-tank
weapons with
ammunition and fuel so allies are
providing many different types of
support
but we have also made it clear that
we will not send in
nato troops on the ground or
nato planes in the air
we do that because we have a
responsibility to
ensure that this conflict do not
escalate beyond ukraine that will cause
even more suffering even more death even
more destruction
and to
declare
a no-fly zone of ukraine
means that we need to impose it and to
impose a no-fly zone means that we need
to
massively attack
russian
air defense systems
in russia in in belarus and in ukraine
and also be ready to shoot down russian
planes and
then the risk for a full-fledged war
between nato and russia will be very
high and that will cause more death and
more destruction
you mentioned yesterday that if chemical
weapons are used in ukraine it could
have a direct impact in nato countries
could this be considered an attack on a
nato ally
i would not speculate beyond saying the
following that any use of chemical
weapons would fundamentally change the
nature of the conflict
it will be a blatant violation of
international law
and
it will have
widespread and severe consequences
the seriousness of using chemical
weapons
of course
becomes
even more obvious knowing that
there is uh there is a risk always for
contamination for for for um
for
that the chemical agents are spread over
bigger areas so this will be a
catastrophe for the people of ukraine
but of course there is also is that
we can see the spread of chemical agents
also into nato territory i will not
speculate uh beyond the fact that nato
is always ready
to defend to protect and to react to any
type of uh attack on the nato country
about china's role in this and a second
question does what does the new military
posture of nato mean in terms of
national defense spending
on national defense spending
i
see a new sense of urgency among allies
so that
they all understand that since we now
need to do more we face the most serious
security crisis in the generation so
therefore we need to invest more than
our security and the their allies
understand that the only way to do that
is also to
allocate more money for national defense
budgets
and i expect allies to agree to
accelerate
the implementation of the commitments we
have made
to invest more in defense and i welcome
the decision for instance by germany to
spend two percent of gdp on the fence
this will really make a difference
because
germany has such a big economy
so
the increased investments by germany
makes a difference for the whole
alliance
yeah well what we we call on china to uh
join the rest of the world in clearly
condemning the
uh russian invasion of
of ukraine and not
provide political support and of course
neither provide any kind of material
support to the russian
innovation of ukraine